Naja, ich meine grundlegende Probleme sind ja, hier auf der Erde hast du ja im Grunde das, was du zum Leben brauchst grundsätzlich. Also Sauerstoff. Kaffee auch. Nee, aber Sauerstoff ist halt so die einige Sache. Wasser findest du ja auch fast überall, aus so ein bisschen verdörrten Gebieten, klar. Aber so ganz grob gesehen, diese Erde ist schon mal gar nicht mal so schlecht, um hier drauf leben zu können. Im Weltall muss ich den ganzen Krempel mit mir schleppen. Das heißt, ich muss meinen Sauerstoff mit mir herum schleppen. Ich muss halt noch irgendwas mit mir schleppen, was mich vor den Strahlen schützt. Da haben wir hier so ein tolles Erdmagnetfeld in nördlichen und südlichen Gebieten. Da leuchtet es manchmal auch ganz toll so, wenn so die ganzen lustigen Strahlen drauf raufprassen, diese Polarlichter.
Eine Heizung nicht zu vergessen.
Eine Heizung, ja, genau. Also so im Weltall kannst du mal warm, mal kalt werden, kommt drauf an, auf welche Seite des Planeten du gerade bist.
Also das ist eh ein ziemlich großes Problem allgemein, wenn man halt so Sachen in den Weltraum schickt, also auch so deine kleinen Satelliten, dass du halt an der Sonnenzugewandtenseite so Temperaturen von plus 150 Grad hast und auf der abgewandten Seite bist du bei minus 350. Also auf jeden Fall extrem große Unterschiede irgendwie. Und das führt natürlich auch zu Spannungen in deinen Geräten und so weiter.
Aber du musst tatsächlich den ganzen Kram mit dir führen. Du musst die ganze Schurzausrüstung mit dir führen und du hast nicht so viel Gewicht, wie wir vorhin schon mal gehört hatten. Also so fünf Tonnen kann ich da mal so hochbringen im Material. Da musst du echt schon aufpassen, was du mitbringst. Also kannst du jetzt nicht einfach mal so halbe Spanferkel mit einstecken, um es dann halt mal schön in den Böcker verputzen, sondern du brauchst halt auch diese herrliche Astronautennahrung dazu.
Also die ist nicht nur ein Tuben, weil es in der Schwerelosigkeit einfacher zu essen ist, sondern auch, weil die einfach dann leichter so transportiert ist, wenn man sie zusammenquetscht.
Ja, und auch gebüttelt halt einfach, ja.
Ist es denn so, dass die Strahlung eigentlich das wirklich lebensgefährliche im Weltraum ist?
Auch. Also Strahlung ist natürlich eins der ganz großen Probleme. Andere kleine Objekte, die noch rumfliegen, die oft nicht drauf passen können. Das Vakuum bzw. die Luftlehre ist natürlich das Problem halt. Zeit brauche ich einen ordentlichen Raumanzug, um da rausgehen zu können. Und ja Strahlung, also Wärme und Kälte ist ja ein Grunde auch Strahlung ist passend.
Was das Vakuum angeht, man stellt sich ja mal vor, die, also ich habe mir das lange vorgestellt, ich habe auch von Leuten gehört, dass das immer noch ihre Vorstellung ist. Der Raumanzug geht auf und peng platzt der Mensch, weil Vakuum, aber das stimmt ja gar nicht, habe ich gehört. Man kann bis zu einer Minute im Weltraum überleben.
Habe ich auch gehört. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon mal ausprobiert wurde. Ich hoffe, es passiert auch nicht.
Ich meine, irgendwo gelesen zu haben, dass es mittlerweile genug Notfälle mit Raumanzügen gab, als dass man das als gesicherte Erkenntnis anbietet.
Ne, platzen wird es wohl nicht sein. Die ersten Vorstellungen waren so, wir kennen es vielleicht aus der Schule noch, diesen schönen Versuch, wir stellen so ein Glas mit Wasser unter eine Käseglocke und machen dann mal ein Vakuum drin. Wenn man fängt, das Wasser anzubrodeln, hat man sich auch gedacht, wenn so ein Mensch einfach rausgeht im Weltraum ohne Anzug, dann wird das Blut direkt anfangen zu kochen. Nee, wird wohl nicht so sein, sondern die Haut schützt schon sehr, sehr gut.
Aber das ist doch ein ähnliches Problem, wie wenn du als Tiefseeltaucher zu schnell auftauchst, dass der Druckunterschied dich dein Blut zum Kochen bringt. Das sollte doch da oben dann ähnlich sein.
Wird ähnlich sein, aber soweit ich weiß, ich hab auch so was gehört mit 1-2 Minuten, dass du auch mal im Vakuum quasi ein bisschen überleben kannst, aber du bist halt sehr, sehr schnell kaputt. Also Sauerstoffunterbindung oder Sauerstoffzufuhr zum Gehirn, die ist halt sehr schnell eingestellt.
Das ist doch mal eine Frage an die Hörer.
Haben wir Ärzte unter uns, die schon mal im Weltraum Patienten mit Schwerelosigkeit...
Also hier Weltraummediziner oder Leute, die genau wissen, was da passiert.
Jetzt, hallo.
0331 70 97 110.
So und wo wir gerade bei Leben im Weltraum sind, hat der Martin auch gleich angerufen. Hallo Martin aus Reinickendorf. Hallo, wo möchtest du gerne im Weltraum leben?
Ich hab jetzt nicht zugehört, weil ich das Radio ausgemacht habe, aber im Weltraum möchte ich erst mal nicht leben. Vielleicht mit dem Anzug, aber sonst wär's schwierig.
Was ist deine Frage?
Meine Frage? Ich hab vielleicht eine Anmerkung. Also ich interessiere mich auch für das Thema Raumfahrt und was damit zusammenhängt Astrophysik und Astronomie. Und insbesondere finde ich das Thema Exoplaneten sehr faszinierend. Und mittlerweile hat man ja um die 1000 Exoplaneten entdeckt. Das wären ja quasi wöchentlich mehr.
Martin, die Regel beim Chaosradio ist, wer zuerst ein Fremdwort benutzt, muss es auch erklären. Was ist ein Exoplanet für jeden, der es noch nie gehört hat?
Ein Exoplanet ist ein Planet, der sich nicht in unserem Sonnensystem befindet, sondern einem Sonnensystem außerhalb, einer einen fremden Sonnensystem sozusagen, wie der Name schon Exo sagt. Also ein Planet, der um einen fremden Stern kreist. Und wie gesagt, man hat mittlerweile um die 1000 entdeckt und es wären quasi wöchentlich mehr, insbesondere durch die Daten von Kepler. Mittlerweile hat er leider nicht mehr funktioniert. Und ja, leider, was ich schade finde, wir haben zwar schon so viele Exoplaneten entdeckt, aber die Informationen, die wir über sie haben, sind doch sehr dürftig. Ja, wir kennen vielleicht die Masse.
Sind aber auch ganz schön weit weg.
Das stimmt, ja. Wir kennen die Masse, den Orbit, vielleicht die Temperatur. Von einigen wenigen kommt vielleicht auch das Spektrum, das Spektrum, das direkte Sonnenlicht einfangen und einige Elemente in die Atmosphäre nachweisen. Aber was man sich ja so wünschen würde, wäre vielleicht so Bilder von Exoplaneten, wie man sie vielleicht von der Erde kennt. Dass man Meere sieht, Wolken, vielleicht irgendwelche unnatürlichen Strukturen auf der Oberfläche. Und das war halt so ein Gedanke, der mich mal beschäftigt hat. Und die Frage an euch wäre, denkt ihr, dass sowas überhaupt physikalisch möglich ist? Also dass man quasi einen Exoplaneten vielleicht in 10, 20 Lichtjahren Entfernung so auflösen kann, dass man solche Informationen hier rekonstruieren könnte?
Du sagst es schon, also 10, 20 Lichtjahre Entfernung. Lichtjahr ist tatsächlich eine Entfernung, das ist die Strecke, die das Licht braucht, um innerhalb eines Jahres sich zurückzulegen. Das heißt, die Planeten, die wir dort jetzt gerade sehen, also die wir halt durch irgendwelche Spektrometer mal gefunden haben, das ist alles Licht, was irgendwie dort so vor 10, 20 Jahren mal an den Planeten vorbeigestrahlt ist. Das ist also schon sehr, sehr lange her.
Das ist ja egal. Ich meine, du musst ja einfach mal die Größenordnung vor Augen halten. Also ich meine, versuch's einfach mal auf der Erde runterzubrechen, zum Beispiel in der Vergrößerung vom Mikroskop. Und dann, wenn du halt diese 10, 20 Lichtjahre in eine Entfernung umrechnest, dann wird dir klar werden, dass das irgendwie einfach mal nicht machbar sei. Also ich meine, wenn du mal...
Ich muss zugeben, das war eine Fangfrage.
Ja klar, das ist schwierig.
Ich hab diese Frage interessanterweise auch mal... Ich hatte mal die Gelegenheit, mit diesem Astrophysiker Harald Dech zu sprechen. Und ich hab ihm dieselbe Frage gestellt. Und der meinte zu mir auch, das ist eigentlich nicht möglich. Das ist aber auch schon Jahre her, das glaub ich, vor 10 Jahren oder länger.
Das wird doch einfach niemals möglich sein.
Ja, das ist der Punkt, da möchte ich aber widersprechen. Denn ich hab was sehr Interessantes gelesen. Und zwar, ihr kennt sicher den Effekt der Gravitationslinse.
Ja, das wollte ich gerade drauf, wollte ich gerade hinaus.
Und wir haben eine, also jede Masse erzeugt ja, kommt ihr raus. Und da gibt es eine entsprechende Gravitationslinse. Im Prinzip haben wir eine solche Gravitationslinse direkt in unserem Sonnensystem. Und zwar erzeugt durch die Sonne. Aus der Jupiter erzeugt eine so große, aber die Sonne aus.
Jetzt wird es aber schon sehr, sehr technisch.
Ich wollte gerade mal sagen, Martin, halt, einen Moment. Eine Gravitationslinse, ich fürchte fast, das ist nicht erklärbar. Kann man in einfachen Worten zusammenfassen, was das sein soll?
Eine Lupe.
Eine Lupe, ja, das kann man vielleicht so sagen. Eine Lupe, die aber erzeugt wird durch die Masse eines Objekts.
Also der Licht, das Licht wird ja auch durch Massen irgendwie abgelenkt. Und du kannst natürlich, also wenn du halt ein Objekt beobachtest, was hinter der Sonne ist, wird natürlich das Licht, was von diesem Objekt ausgesendet wird, durch die Sonne auch gebeugt. Das heißt, wenn du halt genau in diesem Beugungspunkt, also in diesem Brennpunkt der Sonne dann bist, dann siehst du natürlich die Sachen, also wie auch wirklich von der Linse. Wenn du die irgendwie in die Sonne hältst, dann ist ja dahinter irgendwie auch ein Brennpunkt, wo dann halt irgendwie das Papier anfängt zu kokelen. Aber trotzdem, also selbst mit irgendwie der Sonne als Gravitationslinse würden sie halt niemals Bilder hinkriegen, die halt einen Planeten als Planeten darstellen, dass du Wolken drauf siehst. Das ist halt...
Meiner Meinung nach ist diese Information nicht korrekt.
Du könntest...
Ja, ich glaube, da können wir jetzt sehr lange auch darüber diskutieren, aber die Frage ist jetzt, wie können wir jetzt gerade von einem benommten Raumfahrtsintervallus zu uns kommen?
Vielleicht kann ich noch was sagen, wenn das erlaubt ist.
Bitte.
Und zwar gibt es wirklich ein reelles Konzept, welches auch theoretisch berechnet wurde. Es gibt das Konzept, einen Geschwader aus kleinen Spiegeln genau im Bremspunkt der Gravitations- und der Sonne zu positionieren und dann per Interferometrie quasi einen riesigen Spiegel zu erzeugen. Und man hat wirklich ausgerechnet, dass es möglich wäre, damit in 10 bis 20 Lichtjahre Entfernung solch hohe Auflösungen zu erreichen, dass man wirklich diese Details wie Kontinenten der Meere abbilden könnte. Das ist ein französischer Astrophysiker, der ausgerechnet hat. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie der heißt.
Hast du eine Quelle?
Telepolis. Telepolis vor halbem Jahr, glaube ich, fand ich drin. Ich kann den Link mal raussuchen.
Such doch den Link mal raus. Wir haben doch bestimmt eine Mail-Adresse, oder? Chaosradio, etc. etc.
Genau, Chaosradio, etc.
Also das ist tatsächlich theoretisch durchaus möglich.
Also ich könnte es mir mit mehreren Gravitationslitsen durchaus vorstellen, die man halt dann irgendwie aber erzeugen muss oder bzw. durch Zufall zwar praktisch zwei Sterne im richtigen, in der richtigen, also in einer Linie praktisch. Mit einer Gravitationslitsen, so ein Spiegeln, würde ich behaupten nicht, aber ich meine, wenn du was gelesen hast und das fundiert ist...
Ich würde mir die Hand auch dafür abschneiden, aber wie gesagt, das ist ja keine Stimme.
Such doch mal die Quelle raus, schick doch mal an Chaosradio. Das würde mich auf jeden Fall interessieren auch.
Ja, bitte.
Und wir gehen jetzt zurück zur bemannten Raumfahrt. Normalerweise muss ich die Leute, die hier vom Chaos Computer Club da sind, im Zaum halten, damit sie nicht kompliziert werden. Jetzt macht ihr das schon da draußen. Ich fühle mich ein bisschen wie der Letzte, der irgendwie...
Ich finde das total super.
Ich finde das auch total super.
Das ist total spannendes Thema, aber Weltraum ist groß und hat auch sehr viele Themen.
Bewandte Raumfahrt. So, gibt es Probleme? Haben wir gesagt, also wurden gelöst? Wie kommen wir denn jetzt selber dahin? Ist das überhaupt realistisch?
Also du meinst, du und ich jetzt hier, dass wir jetzt so quasi, anstatt jetzt irgendwo ins Auto zu steigen und gleich zurück zu fahren, dass wir einfach sagen, hey, komm, lass uns mal unsere Rakete nehmen und zu unserer Raumstation zurück zu fliegen, ne?
Ja, ja.
Wär schön, ne?
Wär ich dabei.
Aber wie kommen wir selbst dahin? Momentan ist es leider nur wenige Leute vorbehalten, halt mal in den Weltall zu fliegen. Entweder weil du technisch halt einiges drauf hast.
Oder weil du viel Geld hast.
Oder weil du viel Geld hast. Ich sag, das sind so die zwei Faktoren, um in den Weltraum reinzukommen. Das ist ja, also so dieses, ich geh jetzt mal morgen dahin und kauf mir ein Ticket ins All. Ich glaube, das passiert jetzt auch noch nicht so schnell. Es gibt zwar Anfänge, in diese Richtung halt reinzuarbeiten. Jetzt nicht nur durch senkrecht startende Raketen, sondern auch durch Flugzeuge, die schnell genug sind, die auch so die Weltanlinie, also die 100 Kilometer auch ankratzen können.
Es gibt tatsächlich Leute, die das irgendwie durchgerechnet haben und irgendwie so sagen, in absehbarer Zeit von 10 bis 15 Jahren wird es möglich sein für, sagen wir, ja, wenige Zehntausende Euros halt für ein paar Tage oder ein paar Stunden auf einem Hotel im Weltraum irgendwie kurzzeitig zu richten.
Das habe ich vor 10 bis 15 Jahren auch schon gehört. Also merken wir sind nicht so weit gekommen.
Naja, aber immerhin ist doch Richard Garriott zum Beispiel, also so jemand, der mit Spielcomputer spielt.
Oder Mark Schuttelwürstel hat es auch gemacht, hat sich auch mal eingekauft.
Aber die waren ja auch noch auf der ISS, oder?
Ja, genau, richtig. Die sind zur ISS geflogen.
Aber das gab es schon, dass Leute, dass Privatpersonen für Geld im Weltraum waren.
Das waren jetzt sechs, sieben Leute, die es gemacht haben. Das war noch zur Zeit noch, als noch die Shuttles zusätzlich geflogen sind, also das Space Shuttle. Das heißt, da hatten dann die Russen selber noch ein bisschen Platz gehabt ab und zu mal und haben noch mal ein, ihre drei Plätze in der Soyuz-Rakete mal für jemanden freigemacht, der genügend Geld auf den Tisch gelegt hat und damit auch das Programm ein bisschen mit unterstützt hat. Mittlerweile wird es nicht mehr gemacht, weil wirklich die Soyuz nur so die einzige, momentan das einzige bemannte Raumschiff oder bemannbare Raumschiff ist, was wir in den Weltraum schicken können. Das Shuttle ist eingestellt worden. Alle anderen Dinger sind halt, naja, Quatsch, Chinesen kommen ja jetzt auch noch. Ha, genau, die haben wir jetzt noch.
Aber es reduziert sich tatsächlich irgendwie auf den Faktor oder auf den Fakt, dass du halt nicht genug Raketen, Starts auf die Reihe kriegst, um halt irgendwie genug Leute hochzubringen. Wenn man halt wieder, was vorhin schon angesprochen wurde, den Space Elevator hat, wo du halt wirklich dann einen Aufzug hast, wo du unten einsteigst irgendwie und nach ein paar Stunden oder ein paar Tagen dann irgendwie oben aussteigst, dann sind das auch keine Kosten mehr und dann ist es natürlich irgendwie auch durchaus bezahlbar, einfach mal kurzzeitig in den Weltraum hoch zu rufen. Hoch zu steigen und wieder runterzukommen.
Aber das ist tatsächlich noch Zukunftsmusik.
Das ist noch Zukunftsmusik, aber da würde ich durchaus sagen, das kann man, also können wir in unserem Alter durchaus noch erleben.
Ja, im Alter.
So, jetzt, warum eigentlich, dass man Satelliten hochschickt, das finde ich total verständlich, weil man sagt, alles klar, die sind dann da oben und machen uns Sachen leichter, also die Signalübertragung ist viel besser, wir können Weltraum reingucken usw. Aber warum soll es schickt man Menschen in den Weltraum? Also ich meine, okay, es ist geil und man hat es halt mal gemacht, aber...
Na, irgendwer muss die Experimente da oben auch bedienen können.
Roboter?
Die waren zu der Zeit, als die ersten Menschen im Weltraum waren, noch gar nicht so weit. Ja, mittlerweile auch nicht wirklich. Also die Roboter-Technik ist auch nicht so weit fortgeschritten, die muss halt auch bedient werden. Und so ein Mensch ist halt einfach immer noch das optimale Objekt und schnell Entscheidungen auch durchführen zu können, auch mal neue Sachen zu machen. Also das heißt, dieser Hacking-Effekt im Grunde dabei ist. Also was wir ja auch ständig mit unseren Computern machen. Das machen Astronauten, Kosmonauten, Raumfahrer generell auch ständig.
Also ich glaube, das ist einfach...
Technik anders nutzen, als sie eigentlich geplant war.
Einen Blick in die etwas fernere Zukunft. Natürlich wird die Menschheit nicht ewig auf dem Planeten Erde wohnen wollen können. Also wenn sie sich nicht vorher ausrottet, gibt es irgendwann den Punkt, wo sie sagen, wir sind zu viele, wir wollen mal woanders hin oder wir haben keine Ressourcen mehr. Dafür ist die Forschung, die sie derzeit auf den Raumstationen machen, die Grundlage. Also erst mal zu gucken, wie kommt der Mensch klar im Weltraum mit Schwerelosigkeit oder mit geringen Versorgungsmöglichkeiten. Gab es zum Beispiel auch in den USA in den 80ern Biosphäre das Experiment, wo sich halt eine gewisse Anzahl von Leuten in ein hermetisch abgeschlossenes Gewächshaus eingeschlossen haben mit so und so viel Quadratmeter Pflanzen und Wasser und irgendwie Tieren und Recycling. Und halt einfach auch da mal geguckt haben, ist es denn möglich, Menschen über einen langen Zeitraum überhaupt am Leben zu erhalten, außerhalb der normalen Erdumgebung.
Ich meine, das war mit Mars 500 ja jetzt auch schon gemacht worden. Also sprich diese Mission, dass man einfach ein paar Leute 500 Tage eingeschlossen hat und eine Mars-Mission simuliert hatte.
Genau, das ist natürlich dann der nächste Schritt nach der Mondlandung, natürlich halt wirklich dann Menschen auch zum Mars zu bringen. Das dauert halt eine Weile.
Gibt es da nicht irgendwie so eine Casting-Show mittlerweile schon?
Casting-Show?
Ja, da war neulich irgendwas, dass es irgendwie so ein Programm gibt, da kann man sich bewerben und dann werden halt irgendwann zum Schluss ein paar Leute ausgewählt und dorthin geschickt. Die können dann auch nicht mehr zurückkommen.
Ja, es gab da so ein Ding auch. So ein One Way Ticket finde ich einfach mal nicht so prickelnd, ganz ehrlich. Ich finde es echt cooler, irgendwie Leute hinzuschicken zu Mond, Mars, wo auch immer hin und auch wieder halt zurückzubringen. Also das ist das höchste Ziel tatsächlich.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall spannend. Du würdest jetzt sagen, wenn du die Wahl kriegst, pass auf, hier Mars geht klar, kannst du aber nicht zurück, würdest du nicht machen?
Würde ich nicht machen. Ich weiß, dass es genügend Menschen gibt, die sagen so cool, ich will mal zu Mars und ich nehme ein One Way Ticket, aber kann ich ganz ehrlich ethisch nicht vereinbaren mit mir.
Mars ist noch Zukunftsmusik, du hast dich auch genauer belesen über das, was die Leute, die auf der ISS, also der Internationalen Space Station sind, den ganzen Tag so treiben und wie man sich da ein Burrito basteln kann.
Das fand ich ganz lustig, Commander Hetfield, den wir gerade schon mal singen gehört hatten, hat dann auch irgendwann mal, oder ich mein, der Mensch war großartig, der war ja ein bisschen mehr als ein halbes Jahr auf der ISS gewesen und der hat so viel dafür getan, dass dieses Thema Weltraum wieder interessant wurde. Ich meine, viele haben vielleicht seine Bilder gesehen irgendwie, die er vor allen Dingen per Twitter halt rumgeschickt hatte. Sehr tolle, grandiose Aufnahmen von der Erde. Er hat teilweise ein paar Videos gemacht, ein paar Experimente auch gemacht. Und ich mein, die Raumfahrer haben sehr viel Zeit noch neben ihrem normalen Arbeitsprogramm halt und können auch wirklich mal Spürkis auch betreiben.
Wie ist das ungefähr auch geteilt?
Die haben also von, man versucht einen 24-Stunden-Rhythmus auch zu halten dort oben. Ich meine, hey, du fliegst alle 90 Minuten um die Erde rum. Das heißt, Moment, wie oft ist das dann? 16 Mal am Tag oder so kreist du halt um die Erde rum.
Und hast deinen Aufgang und Untergang.
Ja, das ist toll, 16 Mal am Tag Sonnenoffen und Untergang zu haben. Ja, aber man versucht tatsächlich einen 24-Stunden-Rhythmus zu halten. Dieser ist so aufgeteilt, dass eigentlich in der Regel nur 6 Stunden Arbeitszeit sind. Davon sind auch schon anderthalb Stunden für das Muskelaufbautraining oder Muskelerhaltungstraining halt mit eingeplant. Das heißt, du hast quasi 18 Stunden Freizeit, also so 7-8 Stunden Schlaf solltest du haben, sind irgendwie 2-3 Stunden für Essen auch mit eingeplant. Ansonsten hast du so im Grunde Freizeit, was halt ein bisschen da oben vertreiben kannst. Und es gibt halt einige... Einige Raumfahrer, die halt auch dort oben sind, die dann auch für private, interessante Sachen halt auch offen sind. Und ich hab auch so ein nettes Video gesehen, wo... Ich hätte mal wieder ein Burrito essen. Und sind halt Leute hingegangen und haben geguckt, was habt ihr denn an Essen dort oben auf der ISS gerade da? Habt sich einfach mal alles ausgebreitet und haben dann mal so ein Rezept hochgeschickt. So, ja, dann nimmst du jetzt einfach mal hier von diesem klein gehäckselten Schnitzel irgendwie eine Packung. Dann nimmst du noch von da drüben irgendwie ein paar Maiskolben, bzw. Dann gibts auch irgendwo ein spezielles Brot, ein recht dünnes, und da kannst du dir irgendwas zusammenbasteln und irgendwo hast du auch eine Chili-Sauce da rumstehen. Es ist einfach total großartig, wieder versucht, so ein Burrito im Weltall zusammenzubarmen und zu futtern, weil halt dummerweise die Hälfte des Burritos irgendwann mal durch die Kasse oder durch die ISS geflogen ist.
In dem Film Gravity, da holt ja dann George Clooney irgendwann die Vodka-Flasche aus einem Sitz hervor.
Ja, unterm Sitz, also wissen wir noch immer, die Vodka-Flasche liegt unterm Fahrersitz. Dürfen die saufen im Weltraum? Da gibt es unterschiedliche Meinungen zu. Es gibt wohl durchaus kleine Alkoholreserven auch in der ISS und wohl auch kleine Reserven an Vodka natürlich, die dann auch entsprechend von unseren russischen Kosmonauten mit hochgebracht wurden, die wohl auch nicht darauf verzichten möchten. Ab und zu mal so ein bisschen Vodka zu haben. Nee, kannst du im Weltraum auch trinken, das geht. Ist bisher noch nicht irgendwie negativ aufgefallen, aber du solltest halt auch irgendwie bei deinem Sinn bleiben. Klar, wildes Säufnis im Weltall ist, glaube ich, nicht ganz so doll.
Gibt es auch was, was ich auch spannend finde, da leben dann halt irgendwie so zwei, drei Leute. Drei ist, glaube ich, die maximale Anzahl oder eine ISS?
Ne, also sechs ist die Standardbesatzung, also zwei Teams, drei Personen. Teilweise waren auch mehr dort, aber die waren dann halt durchs Shuttle angedockt. Also das heißt, es waren auch schon durchaus, warte mal, das war recht, ein Shuttle, sieben Leute plus sechs Leute, da sind wir dann halt irgendwie so bei 13 Personen, die dann halt irgendwie auch um sind.
Okay, aber sagen sechs Leute, die ständig da sind, gibt es da auch irgendwelche Erkenntnisse von wegen der Psychologie? Das stelle ich mir schon spannend, vor auf so engen Raum.
Also tatsächlich bei den ESA-Einstellungstests ist es ein ganz, ganz großer Punkt, dass es Menschen sind, die auch miteinander umgehen können. Also die jetzt wirklich so ein ruhiger Typus sind, auch einen kühlen Kopf die ganze Zeit behalten können, aber auch nicht zu so einem großen Eco-Trip fahren. Also das ist ein ganz großer Punkt, um halt dort mit bei zu sein. Weil du kannst nicht die ganze Truppe halt irgendwie untergraben von der Moral her.
Und du bekommst in der Ausbildung ganz viel kulturelle Sensitivität beigebracht. Und auch die Kontrollstrukturen haben sich über die Jahre, also da hat man sehr viel gelernt über die Jahre, wie man mit Astronauten umgeht vom Bodenzentrum aus. Denn letztendlich ist man die ganze Zeit dabei, denen Befehle zu geben den ganzen Tag. Und wenn man das nicht verträgt, bzw. wenn man das nicht sensibel macht, dann kann das auch schiefgehen. Es gab zum Beispiel mal auf der Mir ein Vorfall tatsächlich, dass die Astronauten gestreikt haben, nachdem sie einfach überlastet wurden vom Kontrollzentrum. Das haben die nicht eingesehen.
Wie sah das aus? Wie komm ich mehr runter?
Ja, ne, wir machen jetzt halt nicht mehr, was sie sagen. Und das ist halt ein Problem, wenn die da oben sind, dann irgendwie auf sich alleine gestellt sind und eine teure Technik in der Hand haben und man sich nicht einfach mal auf ein Vier-Augengespräch mit dem Chef treffen kann. Ja, und seitdem ist auch viel mehr auf die Tagesordnung gekommen, dass man darauf Rücksicht nimmt, wie es den Astronauten gerade geht und ab und zu immer persönliche Wort redet und mehr Kontakt mit der Familie zulässt.
Das heißt, auch da anscheinend korrekt recherchiert, das ist ja bei Gravity zu sehen, dass die so einen seltsamen Mischmasch haben. Also einerseits sprechen sie sich die ganze Zeit in so offiziellen Formeln an, also dieses Copy und Bestätigung, aber andererseits geht es auch so um dieses persönliche Ding, da erzählt immer einer so Geschichten und die scherzen auch auf eine sehr abstrakte Art und Weise miteinander. Das ist dann auch wahrscheinlich etwas, was wirklich so funktioniert.
Also wenn du selber mal die Streams von der ISS anschaust, auch vor allen Dingen wenn die mal so Spacewalks machen, du kriegst ja komplett alles mit, also siehst, was die draußen gerade machen. Eine Kamera, Helmkamera nimmt das auf, oder halt eine Kamera aus dem Cockpit nimmt das halt auf, also von der ISS selber halt. Du hörst auch den Ton dabei. Also was halt mit der Erde gesprochen wird, mit dem sogenannten Capcom, mit dem Ansprechpartner auf der Erde gesprochen wird, ist auch immer nur eine Person auf der Erde. Das wechsel ich ständig durch, um halt wirklich diese Vertrautheit zu behalten. Kelly auch, ist auch meist ein ausgebildeter Astronaut. Und halt untereinander, dass sie auch dann ein bisschen rumscherzen und so. Das kriegen die hin, weil du brauchst es wirklich, um im Moral zu auch zu erhalten. Das ist halt spannend.
Würdet ihr da hin, für ein halbes Jahr?
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich noch in den Weltraum kommen werde. Das hört sich aber spannend an.
Ich hätte echt mal Bock. Würdet ihr alle machen?
Ein halbes Jahr wäre mir viel zu lang. Ich glaube, da würde ich durchdrehen.
Aber so ein Urlaubstrip irgendwie, statt Ostsee, mal zwei Wochen ISS.
Alles klar, wenn ihr günstige Angebote habt, könnt ihr euch gerne melden, 03717097110. Wir sprechen gleich noch mal eine halbe Stunde über alles andere, was wir vergessen haben. Zum Beispiel ist noch ein spannender Punkt, dass der Weltraumfahrt lange, lange, lange Startensache war und immer weiter privatisiert wird. Da müssen wir auch gleich noch mal drüber sprechen. Vorher gibt es aber die Nachrichten. Sobald ich diese Musik hier ausgemacht habe.
Und zwar jetzt.
Dazu eine große Portion Swing. Eine noch größere Portion knusprige Elektro-Beans. Und dann das Ganze schön live hochkochen. Mittwoch, 11. Dezember, Parov Stella live in der Arena.
Präsentiert von Fritz. Der frühere US-Geheimdienstmitarbeiter Snowden ist offenbar bereit, vor einem Untersuchungsausschuss des Bundestages zur Spionage-Affäre auszusagen. Das sagte der Grünen-Bundesabgeordnete Ströbele dem ARD-Magazin Panorama. Ströbele hat Snowden in seinem russischen Exil getroffen. Das dreistündige Treffen mit dem Ex-NSA-Mitarbeiter habe unter strengster Geheimhaltung stattgefunden, hieß es weiter. Die USA suchen Snowden mit Haftbefehl und werfen ihm Landesverrat vor. Der US-Geheimdienst NSA überwacht offenbar noch mehr deutsche Spitzenpolitiker als bisher bekannt. Die New York Times berichtet, dass die NSA nicht nur das Handy von Bundeskanzlerin Merkel überwacht hat, sondern auch die Telefone von ranghohen Beamten und den Chefs der Oppositionsparteien. An den Späheraktionen soll nach weiteren Medienberichten auch die US-Botschaft in Berlin beteiligt sein, mithilfe von Spionageanlagen auf dem Dach des Hauses am Pariser Platz. Botschafter Amazon wies die Vorwürfe im RBB zurück.
Kein Alkoholverkauf mehr am Abend.
Das fordert ein Netzwerk von elf deutschen Großstädten. Darunter ist auch Potsdam. Die Städte meinen, dass es mehr Jugendkriminalität und Komasaufen gibt, weil Jugendliche spät abends noch Alkohol kaufen können. Das Netzwerk forderte die Bundesregierung auf, den Verkauf zeitlich einzuschränken. Außerdem müsse stärker kontrolliert werden, ob Supermärkte, Spätis und Tankstellen Alkohol an unter 18-Jährige verkaufen. In einem Asylbewerberheim in Brandenburgischen Henningsdorf hat es gebrannt. Die Polizei ermittelt wegen schwerer Brandstiftung gegen einen 18-jährigen Bewohner des Heims. Er soll Möbel angezündet haben. Warum ist noch unklar? Die Feuerwehr konnte den Brand schnell löschen. Die Flüchtlingsunterkunft musste eine Stunde lang geräumt werden. Ein Polizist erlitt eine Rauchvergiftung. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin und Brandenburg liegen zwischen 0 und 7 Grad. Heute Nacht dichte Wolken, etwas Regen. Die Temperaturen gehen auf 6 bis um die 0 Grad runter. Morgenvormittag gibt es nur in der Lausitz ein bisschen Sonnenschein. Danach wird es aber auch da, wie sonst überall in Berlin und Brandenburg, bewölkt. Und es kann auch immer mal regnen bei maximal 13 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin, Charlottenburg, Richard-Wagner-Straße. Die ist zwischen Richard-Wagner-Platz und Bismarckstraße in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. Auch beide Fahrtrichtungen sind dicht bis 4 Uhr früh. Altklinik Wegedonstraße zwischen Semmelweisstraße und Rudower Straße ist wegen Arbeiten an Gasleitungen gesperrt. Zum Verkehr in Brandenburg, A13, Dresden Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Lübbener und Duben sind in beiden Richtungen Tiere auf der Fahrbahn. Fahr dort bitte besonders vorsichtig. Und A24, Hamburg Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Mayenburg und Pritzwalk ist nach einem Lasterunfall voll gesperrt. Also Hamburg Richtung Berlin. Das dauert da wohl noch mindestens zwei Stunden. Letzte freie Ausfahrt ist Mayenburg. Und noch mal zur Berliner S-Bahn. Für die S2 fahren zwischen Marienfelde und Priesterweg bis zum 8. November weiterhin Busse. Bis Betriebsschluss fahren auch auf der S1 zwischen Birkenwerder und Oranienburg ersatzweise Busse. Und zum RE1 zwischen Berlin-Osparnow und Erkner fahren bis zum 4.
November Busse.
Ihr könnt auf die S-Bahn-Linie 3 ausweichen. Kommt gut durch die Nacht.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit man.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch am Chaos Radio hier im Blue Moon, wo wir uns heute im Weltraum befinden und endlich weiten. Naja, ganz so ganz und endlich sind sie noch nicht. Wir haben festgestellt, es ist noch alles ein bisschen schwierig mit dem Weltraum. Aber immerhin, wir kommen schon in den Erdorbit. Also bis da hoch. Raketen, Satelliten, Menschen haben wir alle schon dahingebracht. Und jetzt kümmern wir uns quasi um den Rest. Die erste Frage, die ich da habe an die Herren Starbuck, Leon und Lars, die heute hier sind und uns mit in den Weltraum leben, es gab einmal eine Mondlandung und seitdem ist nichts mehr passiert.
Warum? Es waren ja fünf Landungen. Mit Leuten? Ja, sechs Landungen sogar.
Auch total geil.
Also zwölf verschiedene Menschen waren auf dem Mond, keine Frau, alles Männer.
Ganz ehrlich Leute, wer von euch hat das gewusst?
Aber ich hab das auch lange nicht gewusst.
Eine Mondlandung ist nicht geglückt. Also es sollten eigentlich sieben gewesen sein, eigentlich waren noch ein paar mehr geplant, die sind aber hinter eingestellt worden, weil das wurde auf einmal uninteressant.
Warum?
Selbst die Bevölkerung hat sich gar nicht mehr dafür interessiert. Also die erste Mondlandung war noch super im Medienecho und so die zweite, naja. Und bei der dritten hat man auch tatsächlich im Fernsehen das gar nicht mehr live übertragen. Es wurde erst wieder mit Apollo 13 interessant. Also das war ja eigentlich die dritte gewesen, aber wäre gewesen, aber es wurde erst damit wieder interessant, dass sie halt nicht gelandet sind auf dem Mond. Aber später hat man dann gesagt, so ja komm, jetzt haben wir genügend Mondgestein eingesammelt. Wir haben genügend Messungen durchgeführt. Das ganze Programm ist sau teuer. Lass uns das mal einstellen. Das war 1972, glaube ich.
Aber da hab ich zum Beispiel die Frage, ist es teurer, eine Mission, also ein halbes Jahr auf dem Mond zu leben, als ein halbes Jahr in der ISS?
Ja. Warum? Du musst auf den Mond das ganze Zeug jetzt mal hinbringen.
Ja, aber du musst nicht die ganze Zeit rumfliegen und hast eine Oberfläche auf der...
Fliegen tut's ja von alleine.
Und irgendwie, ja.
Du musst es halt irgendwie nur einmal hochbringen. Weil im Mond ist es so, dass du es dann auch nochmal runterbringen musst. Das heißt, du musst dann irgendwie auch nochmal deutlich mehr Treibstoff mit hochnehmen, um halt auch sauber zu landen.
Also Wärme, Kälte ist noch ein anderes Problem. Der Mond hat ja eine bunne Rotation mit der Erde. Wir sehen ja nur eine Seite vom Mond. Das heißt, wenn wir Vollmond haben, dann wird diese Seite komplett angestrahlt. Und wenn wir Neumond haben, dann liegt die halt so im Schatten drin. Das heißt, du hast so zwei Wochen Helligkeit, zwei Wochen Dunkelheit. Und das kommt halt auch nicht so deutlich. Man heizt sich dann zwei Wochen lang alles so mal schön auf. Und es ist zwei Wochen sehr kalt. Also du musst halt wirklich sehr viel dran machen.
Besser als wenn das weg schon alle paar Stunden wäre.
Ja, das passt auch für ISS gerade.
Ja, und dann ist der Mond auch einfach noch viel weiter als ISS.
Das stimmt auch mal wieder.
Die Raketen, die man braucht, um zum Mond zu kommen, die hat man ja beim Apollo-Programm gesehen. Die waren irgendwie so russienhoch aus. Und das ist halt schon ein ganz anderer Gewissen, auch dann so ein Programm durchzuführen.
Also ich glaube tatsächlich vom Leben dort, also wenn erst mal alles da wäre, wäre es auf jeden Fall einfacher. Ich meine, du hast auch ein bisschen Schwerkraft und so was. Hast in Zweifel auch ein bisschen Wasser. Aber halt erst mal hinkommen ist halt das große Problem. Deswegen schon wieder Space Elevator. Man kann natürlich irgendwie nicht nur einen bauen, der um die Erde rumkreist, sondern auch den, der um den Mond rumkreist. Das heißt, die würden sich dann auch schon fast berühren. Das heißt, man würde dann sich nur noch also oben von dem Erdelevator irgendwie abstoßen, kurz ein bisschen rüber schweben, dort irgendwie wieder runterfahren.
Dann hängst du einfach noch einfach einen am Lagrange-Punkt auf und dann ist der Punkt halt zwischen Mond und Erde, wo sich die Kräfte gegenseitig aufheben, also wo du die richtige schwere Losigkeit hast. Ansonsten hast du immer so schwere Losigkeit irgendwie zu der einen Richtung oder zur anderen Richtung hin.
Wie lange muss das Kabel sein für den?
Du hilfst dann den deostationären Orbit aufhängen.
Also du hast halt nach unten 36.000 Kilometer, nach oben, weil halt irgendwie die Schwerkraft weniger.
36.000 Kilometer.
Also das Kabel selber wäre dann ungefähr so was wie 70.000-80.000 Kilometer. Also es geht halt nicht mit normalen Hanfseil. Die Idee, die sie gerade haben, ist natürlich Kohlenstoffnanneröhrchen, die von der Festigkeit halt schon ungefähr das haben, was man braucht. Da ist halt bisher das Problem, dass sie sie halt einfach nicht in der ausreichenden Länge machen und da reden wir halt nicht von irgendwie, naja sie schaffen halt ein paar Kilometer, sondern sie sind halt irgendwie bei ein paar Millimetern inzwischen. Aber wie gesagt, also das kann durchaus sein, dass dann wie ein Chinese morgen kommt und sagt, ich hab eine tolle neue Technik gefunden und wir müssen nur ein bisschen Zirrettenasche irgendwie in die Verbrennungskammer schicken und dann kommt das lange Kabel raus. Also das würde ich tatsächlich sagen, das ist auf jeden Fall in absehbarer Zeit durchaus in der Möglichkeit der Realisation.
Jetzt ist es ja so, also Mond ist irgendwie zu teuer, deswegen nicht mehr gemacht, die Leute interessieren sich nicht mehr dafür. Jetzt ist es die USA haben ihr Shuttle Programm eingestellt und da sind jetzt sozusagen private Leute, die da reingehen. Normalerweise wird es so mit Misstrauen beobachtet, wenn so Privatfirmen Dinge übernehmen, die eigentlich in der öffentlichen Hand liegen. Wie ist das bei der Raumfahrt?
Ja, ist auch schon ein bisschen länger so. Und ich meine, private Firmen gab es immer wieder, die ein bisschen raumfahrtisch gemacht haben. Aber in diesem Fall geht es wirklich darum, dass gesagt wurde, die NASA macht jetzt nicht mehr die ganzen Flüge zur Versorgung der ISS. Das heißt, es wurden andere Firmen oder es wurden generell Firmen aufgerufen, selber Raumschiffe oder Raketen überhaupt erst mal zu entwickeln. Und da ist vor allen Dingen eine Firma ganz stark hervorgekommen, die Firma SpaceX, die sich auch erst 2002 gegründet haben. Und die haben mittlerweile drei, vier Raketen gebaut, die auch fliegen können. Und die sind irgendwie total stark dahinter, so diese Rocket Sign zu betreiben. Die haben nach sieben Jahren oder sieben Jahren nach der Gründung ihre erste Rakete hochgeschickt, die Falcon One. Das ist wirklich so einfach eine Rakete mit einem Motor dran, also mit einem Verbrennungsausgang hinten dran. Die haben sie erst mal hochgeschickt bzw. auch das Ganze erst mal getestet. Mittlerweile sind die so weit, dass die halt die sogenannte Falcon Nine haben. Die Nine oder Neun halt kommt dadurch, dass sie sieben, äh, Quatsch, neun. Dadurch, dass sie halt neun Raketenausgänge hinten dran haben, die jetzt so ja entweder als Würfel oder halt auch als Kreisland angeordnet sind. Es sind noch kleine Unterschiede noch dabei. Diese Falcon Nine ist mittlerweile auch so ein Transportschiff geworden, womit eine Kapsel, die sogenannte Dragon Capsule, zu ISS gebracht wird. Das ist momentan ein Versorgungsraumschiff, um mal so ein bisschen Wasser wieder hochzubringen, ein bisschen Futter hochzubringen, Sauerstoff vor allen Dingen auch wieder mit hochzubringen. Andere Experimente, die halt interessant sind, auch mit auf die ISS rüber zu transportieren.
Weil man da Sauerstoff hochbringen muss, warum gibt es da eigentlich noch nicht so eine Art, keine Ahnung, selbst erhaltenes oder selbst versorgendes Raumschiff? Kann man das nicht irgendwie machen?
Also die Biosphären-Modell, von dem Starbuck vorhin schon mal gesprochen hatte, ja, das geht in diese Richtung rein, aber es ist noch nicht so ausgereift, dass es komplett hält. Ich meine, es wird schon sehr viel recycelt, also der komplette Sauerstoff wird auch wieder aufbearbeitet, dass du den dann noch mal atmen kannst. Auch das Wasser wird wieder aufbearbeitet. Also bei Wasser sprechen wir nicht nur deine verdauerten Getränke, sondern wir sprechen auch von dem Schweiß, der durch die Klimaanlage wieder eingesammelt wird, aufbereitet wird. Also das ist auch das, was dahinter auch wieder getrunken wird durchaus. Du musst schon ein bisschen hart sein, solltest nicht so stark drüber nachdenken, was du dort zu dir nimmst, aber es geht halt einfach nicht anders.
Krass. Aber zu sagen, ist da die ISS auch noch zu klein für so ein Biosphären-Ding? Weil es braucht wahrscheinlich auch eine bestimmte Größe.
Also es wird natürlich versucht, es sind auch Experimente auf der ISS drauf, wo auch mit organischen Materialien, also Pflanzen vor allen Dingen, gearbeitet wird, dass da auch mal der eine oder andere Salatkopf angebaut wird. Das sieht eigentlich ganz lustig aus, weil die wachsen alle Richtungen quasi. Du hast im Grunde eine Röhre mit einem Substrat drauf und darauf sind die Salatköpfe gepflanzt, die dann so nach oben und unten quasi wachsen rundherum.
Ein Salatball. Um auch noch mal zurück zu den Hackerdingern zu kommen, du hast noch geschrieben in der Vorbereitung, dass Hacker oder Hack-Sachen auch Zulieferer für Weltraumtechnik sein können.
Also es sind halt interessante Sachen dabei. Vor allen Dingen, wenn wir wieder auf Kommunikation gehen, sind ja immer wieder Experimente gemacht worden, um auch Geräte anzuschließen, dass sie miteinander kommunizieren können. So Freifunk ist ja so ein Thema. Wir kennen es teilweise aus Berlin. Da gibt es ja diese ganzen WLAN-Netze, diese Freifunk-Netzwerke, wo jeder mit jedem im Grunde reden kann. Und das ist ja eine interessante Sache für das Satellitennetz, sodass auch die Satelliten untereinander kommunizieren können, sodass sich von einem Punkt der Erde über drei, vier, fünf, acht Satelliten halt ein Signal weiterreichen kann, um an anderen Punkten der Erde wieder runter zu kommen.
Aber das ist ja momentan auch nicht so, oder? Dass im Weltraum alle miteinander zusammenarbeiten? Gibt es da zumindest die...
Schön wär's.
Wie ist denn die Situation?
Sehr viel Konkurrenz natürlich dort und auch sehr viel Heimhaltung teilweise dabei. Wäre schöner, wenn dort viele einfach mehr miteinander reden würden, auch viele mehr miteinander was bauen würden, um ganzes Großes zu erstellen. Aber ich glaube, dann sind wieder zu viele Köche dran und das kennen wir ja, dass sie einen Beil verdärmen.
Wer ist denn da alles unterwegs? Also was ich jetzt weiß, ich dachte auch, es gibt nur eine Mondanlage, also die USA sind da, die Russen sind da und die haben beide noch so Europäer mit dem Schlepptau. Die Chinesen? Wie weit sind die? Also das hat mich überrascht. Im Film Gravity gibt es eine chinesische Space Station.
Ja, die gibt es ja jetzt schon. Ja, es gibt eine Space Station, die, wie heißt die jetzt gleich? Die Tiangong Station. Ich habe wahrscheinlich das falsch ausgesprochen, aber mein Ungarnschinese ist nicht so gut.
Und mit Zopf hast du wahrscheinlich gerade gesagt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich irgendwie. Es gibt eine Raumstation, die vor zwei Jahren hochgebracht wurde. Also es ist im Grunde ein Modul, was dort nur herumschwebt, was auch nicht ständig besetzt ist. Und die Chinesen haben ein Raumschiff schon gebaut. Das Shenzhou heißt das, glaube ich, Raumschiff. Sieht im Grunde aus wie eine Soyuz. Ich meine, irgendwo haben sie die Baupläne halt gekriegt. Der Osten arbeitet zusammen. Ist aber ein bisschen größer gebaut worden. Also in der normalen Soyuz war ursprünglich nur Platz für zwei Personen, jetzt ist Platz für drei und die Shenzhou-Fähre ist halt für vier Personen ausgelegt. Und die haben jetzt auch vor kurzem dafür Aufregung gesorgt, dass sie auf einmal dann mal so ein paar Personen hochgeschickt haben und auf diese Raumstation auch drauf, die vorher hochgebracht wurde, mal für ein paar Tage besetzt haben. Das ist aber die erste Inkarnation dieser Raumstation. Die wird auch 2014 versenkt werden, also einmal so ab in die Atmosphäre rein und verglühen und runterkleiden lassen, ähnlich wie man die Bier halt auch versenkt hatte vor ein paar Jahren.
Warum macht man das eigentlich? Also ich meine, wenn man jetzt schon enorme Kosten hat, um dieses ganze Metall da irgendwie hochzubringen, warum versucht man das nicht oben zu lassen und dann später daraus was schickes zu bauen?
Und wurde auch erst mal gedacht, dass man die Bier auch weiterverwendet, aber die war halt einfach zu veraltet?
Na, es geht jetzt gar nicht so sehr um die tatsächlich Weiternutzung, sondern einfach nur, dass das Rohmaterial, also ich meine, man hat einfach irgendwie Metall da hochgebracht, was halt irgendwie durchaus ja sinnvoll wäre, wenn man das da oben hat, das irgendwie dann zu versuchen, weiterzubenutzen für etwas anderes.
Also ich denke mal, es liegt nicht daran, dieses Material auseinanderzunehmen und wieder zusammenzusetzen, dass einfach zu viel Energie aufwenden würde. Ich meine, du kannst auf so einem Spacewalk außerhalb deiner Schützen- und Raumstation kannst auch dich nicht so viel bewegen. Also die brauchen, um so ein blödes Hubble-Teleskop mal zu reparieren, um da mal Solarpaneele auszutauschen und ein paar kleine Computerteile auszutauschen. Fünf Spacewalks mit zwei Personen, 7 Stunden. Das ist schon mal nicht ohne. Also du schaffst wirklich wenig in deiner Zeit, die du da draußen bist, weil du unheimlich langsam nur arbeiten kannst. Du kannst dich ja nicht richtig bewegen im ganzen Anzug, den du dabei hast.
Da muss man halt wieder Roboter nehmen.
Ja, muss man Roboter nehmen. Also ich glaube, es ist wirklich schwierig. Es ist einfacher, was Neues hochzuschicken, als jetzt die alte Technik zu nehmen. Vor allem bei der Mir war es ja so gewesen, die war ziemlich verbeult, dadurch, dass ja irgendwann mal ein Progress-Schiff falsch angedockt hatte. Oder versucht hat, er falsch anzudocken. Ein Modul ist kaputt gewesen, also es ist wirklich sehr stark verbeult, konnte nicht mal verwendet werden. War dummer, weil das erste amerikanische Modul, was mit angedockt wurde.
So ein Zufall.
Und ja, das Ding hat man echt dann versenkt hinterher. Ich meine, es war auch ein Feuer auf der Mir schon drauf gewesen. Die Technik war halt einfach noch nicht ausgegriffen. Aber es war eine super tolle Raumstation, um viele Erfahrungen zu sammeln. Und das erste Modul der ISS ist auch baugleich mit dem ersten Modul der Mir gewesen. Also es ist ein sehr baugleiches Modul gewesen, tatsächlich.
Wir waren gerade dabei, dass die Chinesen dann ihr die erste...
Ah, whoops, schon wieder das baugleiche Modul. Sehr, sehr, sehr ähnlich.
Was Gutes gebaut. Aber das soll irgendwann versenkt werden.
Scheint eine Markengreize zu werden. Also, macht einen Schlager zu werden. Nee, aber das soll versenkt werden. Die wollen ein zweites noch mal hochschicken, um weitere Tests durchzuführen. Und die dritte Station soll dann auch ausgebaut werden, also mehrere Module zusammenkoppeln. Zufälligerweise soll die dritte Station im Jahre 2020 fertig werden. Das ist das Jahr, wo momentan die ISS ihre Auslaufzeit hat. Also die wird ja auch nur für ein paar Jahre weiter begrenzt von den Zeiten her. Und momentan liegt Finanzierung vor bis 2020. Was danach passiert ist momentan auch unklar. Kann natürlich sein, dass verlängert wird, weil gesagt wird, ey, komm, wir haben gerade diese Station da, lass sie mal ein bisschen weiter betreiben. Oder ob eine Kooperation mit den Chinesen eingegangen wird, die sich auch mittlerweile schon ein bisschen kooperationsbereit erklärt haben. Das ist alles ein bisschen fraglich. Müssen wir noch schauen, wo es darauf hinauslaufen wird. Aber irgendeine Station, so wie es momentan aussieht, werden wir wohl weiterhin im Weltall haben, was ich auch ziemlich cool finde.
Gibt es noch irgendwelche Länder, die Raumfahrt machen?
Indien macht Raumfahrt. Brazilien kann mittlerweile auch Raketen starten.
Die Japaner?
Japan, ja, eigene Raketen ein bisschen auch. Aber die hängen halt auch mit der ISS zusammen. Also die haben da auch Module mit hochgebracht. Also sie sind eher auch in der Kooperation mit da drin, anstatt dass sie jetzt ihren Ego-Trip machen und eigene Raketen hoch schicken.
Und wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit immer wieder geguckt. Gravity, war das so irgendwie alles okay? Und das klingt alles, als hätten die das sehr, sehr, sehr korrekt gemacht. Was mich wundert, weil auf mich wirkt es immer so, weil ich einen Film gesehen habe. Na ja, das sieht schon irgendwie okay aus, aber wird bestimmt ausgedacht sein. Kann man generell sagen, dass das, was sie dir zeigen, wirklich gut ist?
Vieles. Also viele einzelne Sequenzen sind echt gut gemacht. Was ein bisschen daneben ist und was auch der Regisseur selber sagt, so ja, da hab ich ein bisschen Fantasie walten lassen, ist diese Entfernung. Ich meine, am Anfang fühlen sie es halt, ja, die sind in der 600 Kilometer Höhe, wo das Hubble halt auch ausgesetzt wurde. Und kommen innerhalb kürzester Zeit wieder in den Orbit rein. Also es sind ja im Grunde, ich glaube, zwei Umkreisungen von diesen kleinen Teilen, sprich 180 Minuten später, sind die wieder im Orbit dran. Und eine Raumstation, also wie es diese chinesische Raumstation direkt im Orbit auszusetzen macht man auch nicht. Die hängen halt auch auf 300 Kilometer in Höhe. Aber auch vom Hubble bis zur ISS ist ein Unterschied von 300 Kilometern beispielsweise. Von der Höhe her so ganz klar. Wobei ISS hängt so 350 bis 400 Kilometer. Also 250 Kilometer Entfernung.
Das heißt, es wäre viel länger gedauert da hinzukommen?
Zum einen das. Und vor allen Dingen kannst du auch nicht geradeaus einfach mal fliegen. Wenn du auf ein Objekt zuhältst, änderst du dein Orbit und das orbitale Manöver ist halt was ganz anderes als hier auf der Erde durch die Gegend zu fahren. Ist sehr sehr komplex, aber wenn es einer verstanden hat, den geht es ganz gut.
Okay, schaffen wir jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr.
So, ne schaffen wir jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr. Also das sind halt so die kleineren Fehler als diese Übergangssequenzen, sag ich mal in dem Film. Aber grundsätzlich gesehen ist der sehr viele Punkte, sind ja sehr realistisch drin. Also ob es jetzt eine Kerze ist oder ein Feuer, was halt einfach nur als Kugelball durch die Gegend warbart und sowas, ist super toll gemacht. Also das hat mich beeindruckt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Okay, Gravity also, er hat sich quasi dramatische Feinheiten rausgenommen, aber funktioniert. Es gibt noch eine andere Sache, die ich fragen muss, wo wir jetzt schon zwei Stunden über Weltraum geredet haben. Warum hat der Chaos Computer Club vor allen seinen größeren Veranstaltungen eine Rakete rumzustehen?
Na ja, eine Rakete ohne Motor, ne?
Das macht doch erst recht keinen Sinn.
Die Rakete, diese kleine, die man da immer so rumstehen sieht, was heißt klein, die ist ja auch 7 Meter hoch, ist die sogenannte Fairy Dust. Das ist ein Tochter Schiff von der Heart of Gold. Heart of Gold ist das Schiff aus dem Anhalter durch die Galaxis. Das Buch von Douglas Adams. Es gab auch mal ein Hörspiel und ein Film dazu. Das Buch. Und da spielt der Club halt sehr viel drauf mit an, also so durch die Galaxis zu fliegen, komische Sachen zu machen und sich einfach da durchzuhangeln.
Also eigentlich hatten wir mal so einen Camp gehabt. Und auf dem ersten Camp haben wir noch eine Rakete vom Kulturkosmos, also da wo die Fusion mal stattfindet.
Das war auch die Feridaste. Das war die erste Version der Feridaste.
Geklaut. Und irgendwann ist das natürlich dann so als Markenzeichen und Musstenmeld irgendwie in der Rakete.
Genau.
Weil der Munzen.
Ist auch das Tolle dabei. Ich meine, du hast ja ganz, ganz viele Sachen, die du damit machen kannst. Also generell so das Weltraumthema, ob es jetzt die eigenen Marketen bauen ist, ob es jetzt wie wir vorhin schon gehört hatten, halt mal Funknetzwerke aufbauen ist. Kannst aber auch, ja so, die Quadrocopter sind auch super toll geeignet. Also Quadrocopter, die diese kleinen, naja, selbstgebauten Drohnen, wie man es vielleicht heutzutage auch ganz gerne nennt. Ist halt super viel Technik drin, die man auch so für Weltraum nutzen kann. Die ganze Kreisel-Technik, die da teilweise verwendet, beziehungsweise auch die ganze Steuerungstechnik.
Also wenn man keine Propelloren mehr dran hätte, sondern Kreisel, genau, Motoren oder Kreisel.
Was sind die Kreisel?
Du hast immer Kreisel gesagt. Jetzt doch ganz schnell in einem Satz. Was sind Kreisel?
Stabilisatoren. Okay. Die drehen sich schnell und halten stabil, wie so ein Fahrradreifen.
So, jetzt haben wir die ganze Zeit auch darüber gesprochen, was noch nicht funktioniert, was noch zu weit weg ist. Was sind jetzt so die nächsten Schritte? Also was wird denn in der Raumfahrt als nächstes passieren?
Ne, als nächstes passieren wird, also ist mal wieder ein weiteres Raumschiff zu bauen, um Menschen hochzubringen. Also es wird die Dragon Capsule zum Beispiel, die wird umgebaut für Menschen auch geeignet. Also das heißt, dass wir ein Raumschiff auch haben können damit. Ich denke, was auch passieren wird, sind viele kleine Forschungssatelliten auch in die Tiefen des Welts als reinzuschicken. Oder auch so Planeten, die schwierig zu erreichen sind. Merckow zum Beispiel ist sehr schwierig da hinzukommen. Diverse Monde mal beobachten oder mal besuchen gehen. Also Monde von anderen Planeten, die wir so haben. Auf ein Asteroid wird demnächst mal gelandet. Das ist auch was Neues, das habe ich bisher noch nicht gemacht.
Wofür ist das gut?
Um Asteroiden selber kennenzulernen. Was sind das für Dinge? Also bis vor wenigen Jahren, bis man einmal mit einer Sonne durch so ein Asteroid durchgeflogen, also durch einen Schweif durchgeflogen ist, wusste man gar nicht, dass es eigentlich nur so ein Haufen Schneematsch ist, der durchs Weltall fliegt. Also Eisklumpen.
Ja, es gibt ja zum Beispiel Theorie, dass viele organische Moleküle auf der Erde dann tatsächlich von Asteroidanschlägen kommen.
Das meiste von so einem Wasser kommt. Also das meiste Wasser, was wir auf der Erde haben, sind durch Asteroiden reingebracht worden. Ist durch Asteroiden reingekommen, ja.
Aber wo kommen die denn her?
Naja, irgendwo da draußen her, irgendwo aus der ortschen Wolke.
Wieder so ein Begriff. Ist das so, dass Raumfahrt auch das klären soll?
Ja, also man möchte wissen, wo das herkommt, woher auch dieser ganze Klumpen Schneematsch, Eismatsch herkommt und ob vielleicht eventuell in einem dieser Klumpen auf einmal schon so ein bisschen Leben drin war, was dann hier das komplette Leben auf der Erde auch sich weiterentwickelt hatte dadurch dann.
Und das hat irgendwann angefangen, Raketen in den Weltraum zu schießen. Und damit sind wir am Anfang der Sendung und damit beenden wir diese Sendung. Starbuck, Leon und Lars waren hier. Vielen Dank.
Wir müssen noch auf den Kongress hinweisen. Ach so?
Total, ja. Da steht die Rakete wieder.
Nicht, dass ich nicht gleich gefragt hätte, aber bitte?
Vom 27. bis 30. Dezember haben wir wieder den Chaos Communication-Kongress, nämlich den 30. dieses Jahr. Seit 1984 den 30. dann. Und das Ganze findet in Hamburg statt, im Kongresscenter dort, direkt neben dem Bahnhof Dammtor.
Noch viel größer als letztes Jahr.
Ganz viel größer, noch viel größer. Und Karten gibt es vor Ort.
Und mit mehr Raketen.
Es gibt vor allem genug Karten.
Also wer hinkommen will, soll hinkommen.
Dort gibt es also all things, die irgendwie was mit Chaos Computer Club zu tun haben. Falls euch mehr für Raumfahrt oder so interessiert und noch mehr hören wollt, könnt ihr übrigens gerne Raumzeit hören. Das ist ein Podcast, der ist von ESA und DLR, also Europäische Space Agency, European Space Agency und Deutsche Luft- und Raumfahrt-Gesellschaft.
Na gut.
Aber sozusagen, da gibt es noch viel mehr über Raumfahrt und Weltraum zu hören. Ich verabschiede mich, übergebe an Henrik Schröder, der euch gleich im Punk-Nightflight mit Musik bewerfen wird und habe natürlich noch eine Sache zu sagen und das ist möglicherweise wie immer. Lasst euch überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.